okay so um let's go ahead and um work
with one other thing before we get into
some of the editing things and that's
working with um just creating some new
albums in a way that that Picassa just
sort of gives to you and that's working
with with your St and favorite ones
because this might be something you're
going through when you you know you're
coming back from a long vacation and you
just want to be like okay I like that
one I like that one I like that one I
like that one and then basically will
put it into a special folder that has
all of your favorites in there so let's
say I'm going to click on this one okay
and I want actually it's called star it
I'm going to come down here and I see
this little white star it says add
remove star and nothing appears to
happen except for the fact that I now
have this little star on the right hand
side here I'm going to choose this one
okay another star choose this one all
right another star click on that one
another oops I D click it all right see
no harm done there so then I have these
four photos now I want us to go up to
our albums and you'll notice here it
says I have four albums I'm going to
click on this to um to actually uh
expand it and you'll see I now have
starred photos okay I have 84 in there
okay so there's actually a bunch in
there that I've starred in the
past okay and then here are the ones
that I've now put in
there okay so
you'll see that that you probably would
want to actually uh get rid of of some
of the ones if you're going to just
create a new start section okay I'll
show you actually how to remove photos
in just a moment all right it's pretty
straightforward with that but let me
just let me just finish this off so um
so that's very very simple you can just
kind of add those on there now if you
don't want to actually just go right to
your start photos you can create a new
album All right so like I showed you you
can go to file and new new you can come
down here choose new album and you can
also click on this icon right up here
and this comes up all right so I'm just
going to say
furniture
Pi all right and then I'm just say okay
and just like that I now have this
furniture pick uh album that comes up
right and now it's got a zero in there
now there's a couple different ways to
move those in there okay uh one very
simple way is just to click and drag and
now I've got it both in here and inside
my folder all right not too much
difference there right so you see it's
very very very nice and easy like I
basically just click drag put it in
there and then this stays here and now
I've got one folder one photo in that in
that album okay and I can do the same
thing with this one as well now if I
want to select more than one at once
okay if you're on Windows you hold down
control and click if you're you're on a
Apple you hold down the apple key or the
command key and then click right and
then you have all three of them selected
and then I can click and drag wait for
it to highlight and I let go and now
I've got four pictures there okay so
that's pretty straightforward and now I
have those in there now if you want to
delete anything from um either a folder
or from an album it's quite
straightforward you just click on it and
then you find the delete on your
keyboard and you'll see a message that
comes up you're sure you want to remove
the selected image from the current
album and I can click on remove image if
I don't want them to ask me again I can
click on that okay I'm just going to say
remove image for now and now not only is
it's deleted from here but when I go
back to my folders is it going to be in
there yes it's still in there because
remember the difference between albums
and
folders
okay now let's go ahead and continue
working in some of our edits this is
where Picassa gets nice and fun
um so the best way and the easiest way
and the most simplified way of actually
getting into the editing room within
Picassa is to Simply doubleclick on a
picture so you click twice on it and now
you see you're in the dark room so to
speak for your photograph that you want
to work with all right so let's go ahead
and take a look on the left hand side
see what we have here we have the
ability to crop straighten adjust the
red eye um I'm feeling lucky to explain
a little bit and a few other things and
we have also two other tabs that we can
work with when we're editing our tuning
which is basically working with our our
lights and shadows and also our color
temperature and also our different
special effects and these are pretty fun
as well all right so let's actually just
start off with our basic fixes and let's
work with our crop we're not going to
get into all of these things I encourage
you to experiment on these on your own
okay so let's go ahead and go to CR and
you'll notice that the left side changes
and says selected Dimension below and
then click and drag on the image to
select the portion of the image you wish
to crop now this is just one option for
you to do it so if you click on the drop
down you'll see you have all these
different things manual blah blah blah
all these different um Dimensions that
you can work with manual allows you to
just override any of these
Dimensions right where these Dimensions
will now if you Che if you select 5 by7
it will stay with that particular
dimension of 5 by S now don't don't
misunderstand the fact that it's always
going to be a 5 by seven it's more about
the dimensions in this case all right so
you can actually have something that's
you know 10x 14 with 5 by S okay just a
matter of of the aspect ratio of it so
think about it like that all right so
let's go ahead and just start off with
the manual first and all I need to do at
this point is click and drag in whatever
fashion I want to basically draw out a a
box around the area that I want to cross
all right that I want to actually see
and everything else in this gray area
will no longer be there all right so I'm
going to go ahead and come back here I'm
going to click on
preview and it gives me a two second
preview and then it comes right back
it's like well you know maybe I want
this lamp in here so I come right to the
edge I click drag a little bit to the
left and then I do preview
again and then just like that I've got a
different photo okay very simple so I'm
going to go ahead and click apply now to
commit to those changes and then I've
got my photo okay now let's say for
example you have decided you do not want
this crop you decided oh goodness
gracious that is not that's not at all
what I wanted God bless the undue
feature now not only God bless the undo
feature but God bless the undo feature
within Picassa because they have created
it so you can come back anytime and I
say anytime I mean anytime after you
close Picassa anytime time you close
down your computer and still undo
something you've done and this just
isn't for crop this is for doing any of
these effects any of these other
features it remembers everything you've
done for that particular photo so you
can always undo and I can also redo so I
can go back and forth with these so I
can do a couple other things here you
know I can do I'm feeling lucky I can do
auto contrast you're not really seeing
too much stuff here let's go to effects
all right and this is just for the for
the sake of uh let's just adjust the
sharpening a little bit you can see a
little bit happens there okay change it
to CPO all right very good so now I've
just done about what five or six
different things I can always undo and
it tells me exactly what I'm doing undo
sharpen undo Auto contrast undo I'm
feeling lucky and it takes me back all
the way to the
beginning
okay so now we're back to our original
photo all right so keep those things in
mind and and um that'll be very very
helpful for you